a new series of extras starts this week
uh congratulations on well i'm getting a
second series essentially but also
congratulations on already [ __ ] up
it's next week you [ __ ]
[Applause]
hello tiny tim hello
oh
i bet it looks even worse than that keep
going
see
okay what do you think it is that that
people must why must everyone have it i
can't say what i'm thinking
[Laughter]
and they all are too yeah
every every
everyone's thinking
[Applause]
outdoorsman you go out do you i do i i
uh i play tennis i i play golf i run
believe it or not yeah
is that how you get that deep buttery
tan you have
mr norton i'm so excited about your
christmas show
but sir there there be
really that's all you've got yeah
i do look a bit more like parker these
days i don't know that's the problem
you're getting confused
he's kept himself in trim look at you
undo the button go on let it hang out
look at this look at this no
what is the best thing about having one
of these the length
[Applause]
yeah
not too much the width the width the
width is important but i i
i prefer personally i prefer a long thin
one to a short fat one
i can't believe this uh you you had a
birthday and is it 50 years old you're
not 50 years old are you really 50 50
50. yeah i mean you look tremendous
you look like you're 35 if somebody had
to say to me uh how old is it 35 a 35
honestly you look exactly like you did
the first except you're in better shape
remember you used to come out you're
sort of pear-shaped when you come out
now you look great
you look you didn't say that at the time
though no i didn't know what i didn't
know what to think well no you said you
look good now because i looked awful
before that's all you're saying
i needed you to say it before you've got
you're pear shaped i just worked out
faster now
but but how how do you feel at 50 good
right oh yeah
i'm grumpier i think i'm grumpier yeah
yeah i understand you a lot more now
no
you have a dog you should no we've got a
very old cat she's 16 it wouldn't and
it wouldn't be right yet and we travel
too much you know and um uh do you
travel with the cat
no no maybe have a dog when you're on
the road and the cat won't know
like a traveling salesman who has a
different wife in another town yeah but
my cat's on twitter and someone to tell
her
you can't can can you not drive at all
no but do you know how
well i've seen people do it i don't know
but you know
what you don't have a license no okay
you can't drink and drive so what's the
point
that's that's kind of
[Applause]
[Music]
getting caught in the zipper
does that does that mean this is it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yes well that that's
never happened just one of the
advantages of having a very small penis
is that something you brag about no you
don't brag about that i hate to boast
but it's pretty tiny
uh do you think maybe if at 60 it'll get
even worse i don't know because you said
i looked better than i did at 40. oh you
look much better than you did when i
first met you so if this carries on if
you looked at a graph yeah i should be
i'd look like johnny depp when i'm about
70.
that's right
yeah
uh-huh
yeah
yeah call me when that happens
the good the best thing about being dead
is you don't know about it that is the
bet it's
it's like being stupid it's only painful
for others so
it's
it's fine very nice that's very nice for
everybody you went to the achilles heel
of everybody like when you tell a woman
who's you know that her it's you know
she looks old that just hits a woman
deep in the neck
i think you said something about the sex
and the city women like about right it
was airbrushed and i said we now we know
how old you are girls i saw one of you
in an episode of bonanza right
no i was saying why lie there's nothing
there's nothing wrong with being 50 or
looking 15.
i don't think you lose your sensuality
at 50.
and and now that you're older
is it has occurred to you again have you
given any more thought
to god and whether he might be real uh
yeah i think about it every day yeah
yeah he's not
you'd like to be like an evil super
villain yeah that'd be good what would
your power be do you think oh i don't
know i hadn't thought it through i
didn't know i had do i have to i can't i
just i'd be annoying i'm really annoyed
i could do that you'd be not just a not
super you'd be super annoying yeah
anyone that came to batman would go oh
this is just
and what's your better with your voice
i've got sore throat
that's that's it how long have we had
the sore throat just a couple of days
see now i had a sore throat
i've only got a day to live and i said
what do you want to do
and then and then when that didn't
happen why is it yeah and then when that
couldn't happen make a wish foundation
i'd like to go on jimmy fallon please
and so you know that's not what you said
no no no i didn't yeah you want to do
something else and then i said anything
but jimmy
is it true the the story about getting
the call from stephen hawking yeah
yeah well i did i got a call from this
guy how'd you know it was him yeah
last time i saw you uh i thought oh no
i've seen you since then but last time
do you remember when we flew together i
don't remember this it was made me laugh
i was crying that's not a euphemism
that's not some
no one thought it was a euphemism that
aren't they but that that night we flew
together
we have just i'll tell you one more
thing just to show how stupid he is on
on national television um
you won't mind um
we we have these reality game shows
there's so many of them you're getting
and they're celebrities and stuff well
celebrities you say celebrities but now
it's there's they've done so many that
it's like siblings of celebrities and
next-door neighbors and you know sons
and daughters of celebrities and there
was one in particular and i was talking
to carl and i said the thing is with him
he said i said he's only famous because
of who his dad was and carl said yeah
but you could say the same about jesus
[Laughter]
i have faith in uh in people that's nice
you know i think that it it'll be okay
what it'll be okay
have you seen people's track record no
but it'll be fine because we're all be
dead soon
[Laughter]
french have the best food oh rubbish
don't think so they eat horses right
they eat frogs i mean how can that how
did that start how it was i mean it was
the first french boat to go i'll have a
go at that well there are two french
folks
in the backyard and i've just built a
pond pierre oh it's nice yeah what's
that what's that thing hopping that
slimy thing
that's that's a frog we should eat it
what do you mean
can't eat a frog well no not all of it
just the legs
don't eat the frogs they're good for the
garden they ate the slugs and the snail
snails
[Laughter]
you never know do you
[Applause]